我的这个现在资金呢
大部分都放在客转债
有超大的一部分都放在客转债
客转债陆续的到期
那这些到期呢都可以帮我贡献
这个蛮大的一些投资报酬率
像最近的有一档我买盘多的
有一档叫做资金
给各位看一下
最近他就喷出去
今天除了賣自己還要賣龍鋼七
我今天龍鋼七我全賣
不知道哪個人
可轉在101收啊
全賣給他 都給你
101全部給你
我因為我之前這個
低檔買的
之前有到98
最低的98點多
我只是想要
101.5收
結果今天呢 有人101就收了
現在市值65啊 怎麼容易
我覺得蠻划算的
那這個是股票沒漲可轉再先漲上來讓我賣掉
那另外呢有這個
最近漲上來的可轉再也到100塊了那我當初買的時候呢各位你看一下當初買這裡最低的時候才八九十塊我買八九十塊
我只不過想要160賣回去
在今年的12月18號
想不到今天已經可以讓我賣101了
我最好賣102
喔這個賣超快
所以呢這可轉帳蠻好玩的啦
你看你買在八九十
然後突然有人100跟你收
我們只是希望2026年12月收而已
現在就很提早收
所以你的頭暴率呢 非常漂亮
這個不是CBS喔
這不是CBS
這個是用兩種做法
第一個你可以單純買資金的
你也可以開槓桿買
開槓桿買呢 我們在這裡就不講了
不講了 因為現在電話已經很難打
我每次打電話去
有夠難打
平常沒開槓桿 頭暴率可能就是5-6%
一開槓桿
喔 那頭暴率不止
然後假如要提早賣回
像這個
我期待的是2026年12月賣回
現在我今年2月份我就可以賣回來
所以我的這個投報率呢大幅的提升
因為呢
我的時間大幅的縮短然後這個提早賣回呢我又可以繼續再買繼續再買買什麼標的呢買這些啦這裡我大部分的縮短然後這個提早賣回呢我可以繼續再買買什麼標的呢?買這些啦這裡我大部分都有
橫頂、永冠、美額塊
我都有
看起來就是要還錢的啦
橫頂要還我107.69
現在到107了
永冠要還我101.5
現在到101.1了
然後呢,美額塊呢,要還我101
現在到100.4了
都是怎麼樣
都是要還我錢的啦
好不好
那這個CBS呢
也會教你買
CBS我們學院就是賺最大的
賺最大的喔
3006億
他昨天他說他買不到100萬
到這邊賣了600萬
有CBS可以買
反正你就這樣想嘛
這邊一客轉再猜90幾塊
假設你買在96
然後再去
漲上來再去猜喔
根本不用錢
客轉在一張一千股沒有錯
但是CBS呢 你可以用非常小的錢
非常非常小的錢
好 極小
來來來 我們看一下一小多大
這個目前CBS比較便宜的啦
比較便宜的哇 這邊有個園域喔 有1000多塊大風店2000多塊 網品4000多塊所以可轉載
跟各位講
我下半輩子就是靠可轉載
為什麼 因為這些可轉載呢
我們這邊可轉載都是幾百張的耶
就是一檔都是幾百張的 幾倍幾號
我今天上課我就把我的對方單直接給
直接秀給那個學員看
看說那個持有聚賣回日18時期29
這些天數到了他就怎麼樣
他就錢就還我了
所以呢這個真的是很值得一選
很值得一選
科轉載記得好好選
那科轉載呢
你不只可以領再席
也可以做套利
像我今天我有做至今的套利
至今他就本來就是可以做動態避險
那科专在我们有初阶课跟进阶课
初阶课教你利息这种简单的嘛
对不对
以小博大
这算比较简单的
那进阶课呢就教你套力
什么套力
静态套力
动态套力
我们就教给各位
静态怎么套
动态怎么套
动态套力是非常有趣
这些呢都会在这个上课呢跟各位讲